[Music]
every year around
140 million babies are born worldwide
and if we continue at this pace
50 years from now the global population
will reach 10.5
billion people
the world might get a little bit crowded
so let's ban all babies for the next 50
years
what would it be like if we stop
procreating
when would our global population
decrease dramatically
and what would happen when the baby band
was lifted
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we stopped procreating for 50
years
as crazy as it may sound fertility rates
worldwide are already decreasing
more and more people decide to be child
free
if all humans suddenly stopped having
babies forever
our species would be extinct within a
hundred years
but
what if we just paused all new births
for half that time
would we still be able to survive as a
species
putting a stop to procreation would
surely change life as we know it the
majority of people still want to have
babies
if you were one of them
for you this baby band might cause
emotional pain
the tension between those who want and
those who don't want to have children
could escalate and lead to a huge
conflict
there would be a risk that with nothing
to represent the future of our species
everyone would start to do whatever they
want
we wouldn't need to face the people who
will inherit the planet so why not let
ourselves lose
there would also be huge economic
consequences just think about how many
people are in charge of keeping children
safe fed and educated
if the last babies for 50 years were
born in 2022
well there would still be a need for all
these workers for about 15 years but
after that
everything that has to do with children
would no longer be necessary
entire industries would shut down
millions of jobs would be lost
but not all would be negative in a world
without procreation
no kids would also mean you could save
some money
and if everyone did that well the world
could have a better welfare system
if you didn't have to pay for your kids
clothes food and college well you'd have
more income for yourself
you might even see a boost in equality
if women no longer had the societal
pressure of caring for babies they could
invest more time in their own lives and
careers
and the environment would hugely benefit
from this too that's because the demands
for water and food would continue to
decrease
yeah if no babies were born for 50 years
the population of planet earth would
drop to around 5 billion people
this is about the same global population
as we had in 1987
but let's not forget the ban wouldn't
last forever
once the 50 years were over and we
started having babies again
the world would become chaotic
yeah remember how i said 140 million
babies are born every year
well those newborns would now be
responsible for repopulating what was
left of the human race
and now the youngest woman on earth
would be 50
and at the age of 50 the chance of
conceiving naturally is only one percent
so
instead of 140 million babies
we'd likely only have 700 000 in the
first year
but if we spent those 50 years
developing in vitro fertilization
treatments
we could have about 60 million children
that's a bit more comforting
there would be many health risks for
these babies and their mothers too
because of the age of pregnancy there
would be an increased risk for
miscarriage
mothers would likely undergo cesarean
delivery
and having older fathers could result in
children with increased chance of birth
defects some types of cancers and even
schizophrenia
babies would also be at risk of having
learning disabilities and chromosome
related issues such as down syndrome and
because a large portion of the older
generation would now be dead
there would be few people still alive
who knew how to care for newborns
all of our knowledge about taking care
of children would mostly be theoretical
hey maybe after 50 years of not having
to deal with babies
we wouldn't want to start procreating at
all
we could decide that humanity has lived
long enough on this planet and you could
be the last human on earth
but wait
that sounds like a story
for another
what if
you